In ESP the IP header
is not authenticated.
So what if we want to
authenticate the entire packet?
We can use authentication header or.
There are several fields
in the IP header.
For example, time to live or TTL,
that may change in transmission.
The values of these fields
are not included, or
zero out when the message
authentication code is computed.
Does not encrypt anything, but we can
use ESP to encrypt the payload and
then apply To authenticate
the entire packet.
If Is used with transport mode, the
authentication code is in the Header,
which is inserted after the origin or
IP header.
Other important IP set
information in the Header
includes the security parameter
index and a sequence number.
And again,
we will discuss these shortly.
If Is used with tunnel mode, the Header
is inserted after the new IP header.